keeping a low profile the Prime Minister
slipped in and out of Northern Ireland
quietly and had time to reflect on his
flight back to London we have not got a
deal yet that's why the both the foreign
secretary and I but also the Secretary
of State for Northern Ireland will
continue talking to the European Union
to try and find solutions to protect
Northern Ireland's place in our internal
market and the Belfast Good Friday
agreement resolve the Practical issues
and address the Democratic deficit he'd
met parties in a hotel overlooking the
Irish sea where unionists don't want a
border and behind closed doors attempted
to reassure the dup as talk of a deal
with the EU intensifies we have not yet
seen the final text of an agreement
clearly there will be further
discussions between the UK government
and the European Union but I think it is
safe to say that progress has been made
across a range of areas but there are
still some areas where further work is
required Shin fans Michelle O'Neill
should be serving as far Minister but
the dup is boycotting power sharing she
and her party leader emerged from talks
with Rishi sunak confident agreement is
imminent it seems to us that it's very
much game on and we're very heartened by
that we're very very conscious that a
deal can be done should now be concluded
speedily we hope that that will be the
case and then it's a matter for everyone
for each of the political parties to
step up get back to work and deliver for
people here in the north of Ireland the
Northern Ireland protocol created a
trade Border in the Irish sea to avoid
one on this island unionists want Rishi
sunak to tell the EU there can't be a
line down the middle of the UK but the
EU must protect the Integrity of its
single market and squaring that Circle
isn't easy a deal that eliminates any
threat of a trade war with the EU would
be an accomplishment for Rishi sunak
allowing him to say it was him and not
Boris Johnson who finally got brexit
done but at what price Because unless
the unionists are on board there won't
be a power sharing government in
Northern Ireland
with the prime minister in Belfast the
foreign secretary James cleverly has
been in Brussels European commission
vice president Maro ceskovic said they
had a constructive meeting Rishi sunak
will be on the road to Munich next for
talks with EU leaders at a security
Summit this burst of diplomatic activity
a clear signal that the long journey of
negotiation May soon be over
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast